welcome to this video playing Cooper
crappy whatever from the UK at least
that's the flag the CF name Charlie cop
well I don't know this guy came we gotta
Rubenstein okay I think they always was
a tricky line with 95 p.m. let's try
that
the idea being to get something on f7
quickly I go Mikey 54 is stupid
okay but let's let's see I have really
no idea i'm just playing playing this
all on my own I don't have any
theoretical knowledge here yeah yeah I
solid very solid long yellow cannot
cancel oh oh yeah yeah i can take epson
okay you cannot cast a lot not at the
moment all right when i go to f3 he
might even take this now would be a very
very rigid structure okay it's not nice
to go to h3 but probably necessary yeah
the bishops are nice but I'm so far
behind in development this looks looks a
bit tricky
f-16 quick f6 looks very dangerous
hmm yeah this was really bad opening
plane
hmm
can I'd like to move this Bishop on
everyone at some point yeah black is in
excellent shape here f6 is probably very
good for him
not sure if now on if you should
prepared first with them Sam oof but
black needs to open up the position if
he if he does so I think I'm in very bad
shape all this took took far too much
time
yeah f6 is the non move yeah I had
considered this also it it might be good
as well okay I just I just believe him
taking only five and he can take one
take on g5 a category 5 i'm not sure at
all but if I have spent even more time
here then in addition to the positional
problems i also will have fun time
problems and this will be too much time
and position is too much probably 94
it's really a big big threat
and maybe maybe I can can consolidate
this night not to F to be sure to need a
couple of moves and then probably it is
fairly stable this position yeah yeah
guess with this piece the bishop at
least has some some sort of function
here taking the pawn right to have to to
protect you for and d3 night a for might
be able well maybe I need to to play
rugby one after night a fourth it's not
what you want to do but I feel somehow
that the worst may be over night to d5
online technologies okay maybe 96 and
try to attack e5 this could be a could
be a good idea but I tried Bishop to
Bishop to age 51 wondered what I wanted
to try night this and I can play 97
anyway wait if I go before before and b5
if he goes to d7 i play b 5 i'm catching
the bishop right so we cannot go to this
happen okay
I don't mind night a for something too
much yeah now be five doesn't really
help because him he can just drop back
if he wants to yes but I think this one
should be okay intending bishop age five
yeah I think the worst is over I have
quite decent coordination now
hmm Wow I'm starting to get really
optimistic yet maybe this is not called
for but 93 should be fine
hmm 93 this is this is hmm
okay but why not this can do that right
I give this check I can go to e2 and
then to e3 on III the king is fine
you should be five just here and the
king is perfectly fine
yeah but what are you doing now your
night and f7 is also hanging
mmm i can i can also play a for quite
irritating
five know
hey looks like i should be winning more
material but i don't see it probably
just just blind here
check
I'm boarding
check me quite a funny made yeah I
somehow wriggled out of this after the
opening it was really bad I mean
something around a couple of moves later
I think black was like must have been in
an absolutely act excellent shape yeah I
compounds play Knight a5 which is
certainly not bad 95 2 h for this kind
of idea I thought f6 but not sure about
the timing here of six
just trying to open up as quickly as
possible it gives black or upon upon
advantage gap why do I this completely
completely uncoordinated him I cannot
cannot really am move here that it's
difficult to even suggest something
let's say I would go here then night and
ID for is awful also no g4 yeah this was
a really bad night g5 Isabel rules or
maybe night the night g5 I think it's
playable but this is bad I really
underestimated this he's getting long
castles and everything with with temple
basically and yeah black is this
excellent here and then some somewhere
here he lost the thread this is still
good for black no doubt about that I
really don't know maybe here maybe here
9726 Anders this could be could be a
possibility hard year hard to defend the
veep on this is good this is good
this I know Here I am NOT saying why
this great or anything but it seems like
I'm still some we're playing here look
to g8 rook rook to GA day this is a good
news com yeah the computer the test I
should play b5 here and then this one
gap understandable it's a good position
for the night yeah but I played this one
and the computer now suggests look H 2g8
which is quite thick right now is it
threatens this one and yeah take here
you get e5 and black Assad earlier on
right here kompis asses this is equal
not sure but black is perfectly okay
probably better still and here yeah here
I actually do prefer white I mean I'm
just I have a good bishop I mean
slightly weekend I'm not sure that this
is such a great piece and with something
yeah around here it is something
guaranteed is a winning position in just
getting this and yeah I actually kept
the winning position I thought I maybe
had something better but the computer
doesn't find anything as well alright
thanks for watching